[Music]
this part's very powerful guys listen
carefully
very powerful i really think that the
reason i was wondering how did mltw
reach out to me oh because adam salas
suggested me i really think it was
check out our sponsors nature's blends
they specialize in premium ethiopian
black seed products
their products are fantastic health
supplements and also from the sunnah
the website is in the description link
below you can also use a discount code
salam 10 for 10 of their products
assalamualaikum today two brothers and
sisters and dear friends hope you guys
everyone shall welcome to this video
before i start one of the priests of the
supreme counter the most merciful the
most trust or praise is glory and
gratitude belong to him
and our brothers and sisters i came
across a video uh recommended on my
youtube of brother fuzzy truth
uh as you guys may know um that he is in
kenya with
uh brother uh slim
and adam saleh and himself and also i
saw um brother jay dean there as well so
they're they're doing
amazing work some charity work which
we're gonna give a link to that insurer
to support them
uh this video really touched me you know
i've done a lot of videos trying to give
advice about about huge uh fuzzy troop
um and tough times that he went through
some videos trying to support him etc
so um with this specifically video
really really touched me like so much so
that i actually um like you know i shed
a tear
um seeing the results of it let's watch
this video
uh and also i've got shivers i've really
got sugars that something can mention
literally when i was watching that video
i got shivers in my body well light it
touched me so much
um and let's watch intro let's get
straight into it and let's not waste any
time
oh thanks to you guys muslims of the
world um thank you guys so much
like this is a life-changing experience
and as you guys can see you have the
opportunity to change so many people's
lives for just a 100
donations so thank you guys so much and
this is only the beginning of the change
we're going to do for this world in sha
allah
i complain about such little stuff when
i'm back home and i like worry about
things that don't matter and over here
all he wanted was his vision back in his
eye and it was done for 100 dollars
yes
[Music]
it's crazy
[Music]
so okay so that video really touched me
guys well i i'm being honest i've been
i've
really been touched by his video now a
lot of you guys might watch this
and sadly i love not only i'm not
talking to you guys there's a lot of
people out there who send a lot of hate
to him yeah
um and while he like me personally every
time i've advised him anytime be adam
saleh or whoever it may be
well i never ever in my i never think to
myself i'm better than this person or
i'm practicing
you know why because i don't know where
i'm going to be i don't know where i'm
going to be and this is how we should be
bringing sisters always keep ourselves
humble
not go to extreme where you think that
you guided yourself because this is
arrogance and i don't want arrogance in
my life
and while i believe for the truth it's
100 times better than me and many other
people you can see from his heart
when you watch this video and he cries a
lot of people think oh cringe
or look at this cry in this faith one
light that is so dangerous
it's so dangerous yeah so for those who
are watching this and thinking oh yeah
he's crying while
he i can see the sincerity from this
world yeah i can see it
yeah and he's genuinely touched by i'm
touched because i know how it is on the
ground we go and do charity work
sometimes
when we fly out there when people like
that auntie doing dua
it's on you can't explain that feeling
of somebody
that you have just been a facility to
changing their life
subhan allah and it's it's so so
powerful uh to see him and you can see
he's
very very like emotional in that context
and i understand where it's coming from
but
it's just it seems like there's
something more deeper than that and as i
was watching the video i realized
what that was you know because yes he
was crying for them
but there was something internal as well
going on this next clip
will show you what that was which i
believe i believe
that's what it was let's watch this
benefit the most on this trip so i'm
gonna actually start off with you and
then we'll go from your right and you'll
go around
okay so my mom has been making dua for
so long that i get closer to my dean
whenever i call her about my depression
whenever i call her about
an incident that happened whenever i
call her about being a failure in my
career now and things not going good she
always goes pray to allah
and i will tell you mama and i just and
she was okay like you know you're
brushing me off and after my july 15th
incident during july 15 i was explaining
to a couple of brothers yesterday that
was the closest that i ever felt
connected to my faith which is very odd
to me because the worst thing of my life
happened
while i was connected to my faith the
most and i haven't been connected to my
dean or my faith
ever since um i just lost the connection
and i didn't force it i know who my
savior is i know what my lord is but
i wasn't praying i wasn't doing the
right things i wasn't you know i was
still on twitch
smoking drinking doing all that stuff
which i already have quit and it's been
a while now but
what this trip has done to me naturally
is regain my connection with my faith in
my deen
and i plan on going back to los angeles
and not publicly telling everybody like
oh guys
i'm because people are asking are you
somebody muslim i don't know i'm going
there and saying hey guys i'm muslim
make sure you're praying five times a
day before myself privately
i know i want to go back home to l.a and
be a muslim and start praying and start
making duas and start doing the right
things because
if this is what it feels like to be
around you guys who have treated me like
brothers heard my worst stories
and everything you guys have given me
nothing but love and feeling the
fulfillment i feel from this i don't
even want to go back home to l.a right
now and be in that environment like i
would want to stay here and just keep
this going
so everything we've done on this trip
has i think opened my eyes open my heart
this part is very powerful guys listen
carefully very powerful i really think
that the reason
i was wondering how did mlt reach out to
me oh because adam saw that suggested me
i really think it was because my mom
made the dua that i get closer to my
dean and it came true
is so beautiful to see the brothers
together brother jaden is there may
allah bless him jd
is someone a brother like whoever
person is a very beautiful brother and
he's actually inspired me to get closer
to the quran and may allah bless him
inshallah one thing that fousey troop
says
is that his mum's dua got answered via
that trip now allah works in mysterious
ways now when we
sometimes want something from allah we
make a dua we think okay allah help me
memorize the quran we think
allah is going to send some kind of
revelation down etc and i'm going to uh
memorize somewhere
like you know it's going to happen i'm
going to wake up with it doesn't work
like that
allah will direct you to a path where
people recite the quran you befriend
people who are memorize the quran allah
will answer your
what in mysterious ways and that is what
is beautiful
make your dua and you'll see things
changing allah keem on the straight path
you start losing bad friends
um and while he what he said that was so
profound because it reminds me of imam
bukhari may allah have mercy on him
where his mother who was half of the
quran
and what they say is that when imam was
born
he was born with um an eye disease
um and me myself i have an eye condition
as well but
you know it's so that's why it's a bit
close to video like subhan allah and the
thing is with him
he eventually became blind imam bukhari
and his mother made so much love for two
three years
continuously constantly making so much
dua that his eyes got
so good his eyes recovered so well that
they would say
by just the moonlight he would be
writing books
just the moonlight yeah and you know how
he was back it was not electricity yeah
and problem says well why this is so
profound and for brother adam for
brother slim for
jay deen for footy troop there's a verse
in the quran where i want to mention
inshallah
from allah ali i'm going to recite for
you guys inshallah i'm going to go for
the english inshallah and i'm going to
end the video on that because it's a
beautiful reminder
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the verse goes on but i just want to
stop there allah says
so by by the night when it covers and
the that
and the day when it shines and by the
one who created the male and the female
surely the ends you strive for are
diverse
as for the one who is charitable mindful
of allah
and firmly believes in the finest reward
we will facilitate for them the way of
ease as for the one who is stingy
indifferent to allah cares about allah
and staunchly denies the finest reward
we will facilitate for them the part of
hardship and their wealth will be of no
benefit for them when they tumble into
hell
it is certainly upon us alone to show
the way of the way to guide us
and surely to us belong the this life
and the next
brothers and sisters subhanallah saying
here
as for the one who believes in allah we
will facilitate for them ease you know
what that means
you know what that means if you believe
in allah
allah will make good deeds easy for you
if you believe in allah make jannah easy
for me let me
grant jannah allah will open doors for
you to make righteously charity work
being good to neighbors these good deeds
will come to you and be made easy to
your brothers and sisters
and if you guys are watching this
brother says
like i know like a lot of people saying
you know like you lost like
views et cetera maybe even going for
some uh wherever it may
other stuff in your life allah says you
might hate something which is good for
you
anything that brings you closer to allah
which is a calamity whatever it is it's
a blessing
anything that wakes you up and says you
know what this is bringing me closer to
allah
this this is a blessing from allah
and i'm going to end on that brothers
and sisters we ask allah to keep
brother fuji's troop on the stage
inshallah they will come brothers and
sisters we will meet in person as well
and brother adam salazar may allah bless
him and brother slim and brother j
dean that all together doing charity
work
says in the quran for the man who will
be when he dies
when his life is taken and he's done no
good deeds
and he's never helped anybody he would
not come back for salah
not for hajj not for umrah not for
fasting he would say send me back so i
can give him sadaqah
may allah accept it from them and the
link is going to be below give inshallah
a hundred dollars
to open somebody's eyes subhan allah
what an amazing gift from
sisters till next time assalamu alaikum
warahmatullahi wabarakatu shares with
your friends and family inshallah
um may allah bless you guys till next
time goodbye